in other news president Trump's picked
to lead the FBI says he would quit if
the president ever attempted to impede
an investigation Christopher Rae made
the comments yesterday during his Senate
confirmation hearing former FBI director
James Comey said he was fired after
refusing to pledge his loyalty to
President Trump
ray told senators he would also refuse
no one asked me for any kind of loyalty
oath at any point during this process
and I sure as heck didn't offer one that
the president asks you do something
unlawful or unethical what do you say
first I would try to talk him out of it
and if that failed I would resign ray
contradicted the president when he said
the Russia investigation is not a
witch-hunt he is likely headed for an
easy confirmations Senate Republicans
say they'll put out a revised health
care bill this morning they want to pass
something before next month's recess
president Trump yesterday warned
senators not to let their supporters
down I will be very angry about it and a
lot of people will be very upset but I'm
sitting waiting for that bill to come to
my desk I hope that they do it they've
been promising it for years Nancy Cordes
is on Capitol Hill with the changes in
the Senate bill Nancy good morning good
morning and GOP senators are going to
get a chance to see the text including
those new changes today but nor the
holdouts we've spoken to say from what
they've heard so far they are not swayed
CBS News has learned that the new draft
adds in billions of dollars in opioid
funding it also adds more money to a
Stabilization Fund to help low-income
Americans afford insurance on the
individual market and it funds all of
those changes by leaving some of
Obamacare taxes on the wealthy in place
like a tax on investment income and a
tax on salaries and bonuses for health
care CEOs now those taxes are a big
turn-off for conservatives who already
opposed version 1 of the bill and
there's no indication that this new
draft addresses the biggest concern for
moderate Republicans which was the deep
Medicaid cuts in the first bill that
they say
will hurt millions of their own
vulnerable constituents there were ten
Republican senators at the very least
who opposed the original draft of the
GOP s health care bill so far we've seen
no sign of a shift and Jeff leaders need
eight of them to come around if they
want to pass a repeal of Obamacare Nancy
Cordes thank you very much